this story gives a whole new definition
to the term puppy love as final exam
speak closer a college in the UK has
found the key to distressing their
overly caffeinated students a puppy
playroom organised by the school Student
Union in coordination with the Guide
Dogs charity attendees are asked to make
a small donation to the charity in order
to play with the puppies which are all
Guide Dogs in training unsurprisingly
the puppy room was already fully booked
with the reservation list at maximum
capacity so I want to do this story
because I actually have a friend that
when they're doing this in LA now to
parties you can rent puppies and then
you just get into a room full of puppies
and my friend did this and she just had
puppies jumping all over her she said it
was the most wonderful thing ever she
felt like nothing better than puppies
yeah all over you is this just the
greatest thing ever puppies all over
there's a place called cat town and it
is a cat cafe and you can go in and I've
been there you can reserve a time and
you all go into this room and just sit
and hang out and drink coffee with cats
and pet them but you have to like let
them do their own thing well now I know
what we're making our gift yeah yeah
puppies yeah I'm all about it we had
puppies in the office look at one of
those they like kind of corralled them
and we just like sat down and so you did
this no it wasn't yeah I mean yeah it
wasn't a therapy thing but it was
amazing it was therapeutic yeah sure I
mean this is the first time I've wanted
to go back to college like ever
yeah and it's because I want an excuse
to send the room with puppies yeah now
I'm a big dog I love dogs I do not like
cats I'm allergic to cats which half my
family's allergic to cats and the other
half has cats which I always thought was
that there's some therapy in there
but you you like them equally don't you
because I see what you're doing on
Instagram you animals and you know I
think maybe they should do like a new
study where they just put like really
stressed out dogs in a room full of
babies
and so it happens they're like flip it
around like let's make this interesting
yeah watch what happy babies yeah yeah
why would not go well but no animals I
love them all I think that it's great
that they're using this therapy I wish
they would use rescue dogs to do this
for sq puppies maybe and not those all
seems like purebred so that what they're
getting training so they're at least
like right so these are these are guide
dogs and training and that the one that
my friend did all the puppies were up
for adoption after so if you want but
yes they shouldn't be doing these out of
mills and rats are you equal are you
equal I don't have two cats awesome all
right and dog this is like how does
everything I think it's a gay guy you
think but I know I think that like for
me it's like I love them all and I will
totally deal with like three hours of
seasoning for the right animal yeah
they're just so cute alright well I
think we're all agreed that this is all
good so why don't you you got a favorite
animal rescue place um well no kill LA
I'm a big fan of that obviously because
there no kill shelter animal acres I'm a
big supporter of them they're a farm
animal sanctuary located in Southern
California so yeah I just I mean any
place that's doing good for animals I'm
all about them yeah I'll pimp those two
out right now alright not much debate
here we all love animals right you love
animals don't you are you a cat person
or a dog person do you like ferrets they
like hamsters do you like lizards what
do you like let us know in the comments
right now